otra crisis acude al fútbol francés la
capitana del equipo femenino Wendy
renard ha anunciado que abandona la
selección alegando un desacuerdo con la
forma en que se gestiona
amo a Francia por encima de todo no soy
perfecta ni mucho menos pero ya no puedo
respaldar el sistema actual que está
lejos de los requisitos necesarios
incluso almas alto nivel es un día muy
triste pero necesario para preservar mi
salud mental
renard 142 veces internacional con
Francia desde 2011 no participará en el
mundial de Julio una hora después de su
anuncio otras dos jugadores estrellas y
María Antonieta totó siguieron su
ejemplo y también anunciaron que ya no
querían jugar con Francia una vez más
los directivos y sus valores fueron
señalados con el dedo y aunque ninguna
de las jugadoras Ha nombrado a nadie en
particular todas las miradas apuntan a
la seleccionadora del equipo corindiac
que ha recibido duras críticas por
marginar a jugadores estrellas en el
pasado
creo que las cosas van a cambiar y a
cinco meses del mundial la federación va
a tener que reunir a todo el mundo para
asegurarse de que las jugadoras estén en
las mejores condiciones posibles para
hacer un buen papel en la Copa del Mundo
según la federación francesa de fútbol
su comisión ejecutiva el asunto el 28 de
febrero